what's the deal man it's your boy caleb
for real friend check me out on the
bootleg cav podcast
yo blue light cap show here special
guest man my guy
kalyn what's going on now caitlyn i
always say kaelin too for real caitlyn
for real for real how what is the proper
uh
what is the proper pronunciation for
people who don't know
uh it's kayla for real for real okay but
you could say two for real too because
two for real is just
for real for two for just the two for
two of them
yeah yeah shout out to my guy
we're just gonna we're just gonna call
you twofer twofer kaylynn twofer
for uh i got the two card a lot i like
that
anyway yo uh you got your new uh project
coming out well this is a deluxe
of your project that came out earlier
this year two for two deluxe
how are you approaching the deluxe thing
because sometimes we get like four new
songs and then you got people like uzi
who put a whole [ __ ] new album out
what are you doing
i got like six of them so it's six new
songs six new songs yeah
any new features like who's on that dirk
on there
um shout out to the city blue books on
there
you feel me um maida made a singing on
there you already made it yeah yeah
rock nature does his whole team yeah
that's it that's all right now
well listen um you you know what i
appreciated about how you kind of like
started to heat up was
you like you like went to atlanta
you went to the south and he was tapping
in with like guys like dj nguyen
and like yeah you was like you kind of
like like
heated up like made sure like your
relationships and like you were popping
in like other regions
as well as la where i feel like a lot of
times in la like
this is like such a a small world
sometimes and this is
easy to get wrapped up in being hot here
but very few artists from out here
in the last decade or so have like
really transcended nationwide you know
what i'm saying
right i would say like you feel me it
was never like planned
right like that that wasn't never really
a plan it was just where i was ending up
and like looking back at it now i could
go back and be like yeah well i did this
and then this helped this
and that like but like at the time it
just was like hey [ __ ] it i'm gonna just
go to atlanta
like do you think that that helped you
though like in the long run um i felt
like
atlanta gave me the confidence that i
needed to be
an artist overall you know because it's
like in atlanta everybody uh
is everything this is facts like
everybody does everything and then uh
like to me just from what i see is like
everybody is celebrity
it don't matter what you do you could be
a janitor you could be a rapper you
could own a club you could
you feel me have a car wash it don't
matter what you is but like
everybody promote theirself as like they
the best [ __ ]
this is the best [ __ ] you got to come
right here to get this like all right
you feel me so like
just wait with being out there and just
being like seeing everybody else
just like being so confident no matter
if a [ __ ] had five followers or ten
followers like he knew he was hard
you know i had like a lot of trouble in
the beginning like understanding like if
i was like
good at making music because it's like i
liked it
you feel me the people around me like my
homies and [ __ ] was telling me it was
cool but
they're my homies you know they're what
they're supposed to do like and you feel
me and they tell me [ __ ] was weak too
but it was just like
are you telling me this is good for me
are you telling me this is good enough
for the world
you know what i mean so it was more like
just being in atlanta
oh no i just kind of grew as a person
fully you know not really like saying
like the me like
the big music scene because like when i
first got to atlanta
i was doing the same [ __ ] i was doing in
l.a like i was recording in the house
like all the two for real the whole
first
two for real was recorded in the house
yeah yeah
like what's crazy too because like you
said like i think like a lot of people
you left home went to college in san
diego played football there
then went to atlanta to just get the
music ship going like
you know people don't realize like
leaving your hometown and taking that
like
risk that scary unknown like just
leaving
it helps so much because dude you can't
be scared to grow like an expand it's
cause like
you gotta meet people everywhere like
nine times out of ten like i'm not gonna
sit up here in front i could like the
city is [ __ ] with me because
a lot of people wasn't you know so it
was just like
all right oh [ __ ] i'm gonna just go out
here you know
see if they [ __ ] with me yeah i just
think that like people get so
i feel like when you're at home and you
get comfortable mm-hmm you almost gotta
leave home
to realize like yeah it's like sink or
swim you ain't got your family around
you got nobody around that's what it was
like [ __ ] back was all the way up
against the wall it was like
you feeling either you're gonna make
this [ __ ] happen are you not you know
and just like hang on i'm really blessed
i don't know what it is like
i couldn't tell you like if it's like
man should just start working and like
people be like i got a lot of the hard
work ethic
and stuff like that right and then i
look back and see it and i like i
enjoy working hard and stuff like that
but you get lost when you're doing
something that you want to do
like you tell me like i love doing this
[ __ ] so it don't feel like i'm working
hard
right it doesn't feel like that to me
like you feel me so when people be like
oh like he's so humble
and he like you feel me he worked so
hard he put in so much work like
like this is what you're supposed to do
yeah yeah i mean you live if you love
what you're doing they say you never
work a day in your life yeah i ain't
working this [ __ ] is just
you feel me it's work but i ain't
working right you know
it's work because other people are
involved now so now i got to like you
feel me
it becomes work when it's like other
people's livelihood or is that stupid
all right [ __ ] like you feeling me like
this is how they make they money that's
how they feed they family and stuff like
that so you got to do your part
so that to make sure everybody feel me
because they're taking a chance on you
you feel me so when they become to that
that's when i started understanding like
it's work
but making music is not work for me you
know
like that [ __ ] just fun like i like to
make music you know and i'm always going
through [ __ ]
like yo you always are inspired to yeah
you like you say if you're always going
through [ __ ] or
you're living your life you're going to
have new content to write every day
that's some real [ __ ] people don't be
living or people be faking what they be
living that's real bro
people don't be living like that they'd
be on their phone at home or they'd be
yeah but [ __ ] go on a song and talk
about you killed six [ __ ] today
like you ain't no you didn't you've been
playing 2k
all day like right right around me i'm
gonna talk about 2k
because [ __ ] always want to use lebron
nigga's not good
hey man shout out to my son that's my
son man my son i always be picking the
lakers i'm like bro come on man like
pick somebody up
three randoms man three randoms come on
yeah i always tell them i'm like yo just
hit the r2 let the randoms pick and
we'll see who wins
yeah or let's pick the two worst teams
in the league and let's see who plays
let then let's see who [ __ ] wins
yes let's see who's good with the
pistons the homies always use the lakers
in the bucks man
yeah giannis is a cheat code in the game
too man yeah
um what uh so
what when you went to us so if people
don't know you
graduated high school you went to san
diego state university
to play football yeah um how talk about
your football pass how long did you play
like your whole life i played football
like from when i was like
my first time playing football is like
10 years old when i played up until
i was 21 like yeah so it was like
22. that was would you say football was
your first love before music
nah cause i always loved music like i
always been like i got michael jackson
tatted on me
like i always been like a big oh yeah
that is michael jackson his feet are
moonwalking
so like i always been like into michael
jackson and [ __ ] like in just music
period he might have been into you too
earlier
[Laughter]
don't do that man come on i'm saying he
might have been
no no we're not going i'm just all right
all right all right continue continue
you're always into music
yeah i always like music though but it
um
it's always been like having two
girlfriends yeah yeah so it's just like
somebody always like lacked somebody
always felt like
i wasn't giving it enough or something
like that and then i got it like that
was like one of my biggest things like
my coaches just be saying [ __ ] like
like you to focus on rap like you need
to worry about
what you need to be doing and [ __ ] like
that even if i wasn't [ __ ] up it
always was a thing
you know like it always was a thing and
i'm not gonna act like i was the best
player like i'll be [ __ ] up like i'll
wig out
and i'll really not be thinking about
what's going on like
but to the extent i had a lot of like
the people around me made it seem it was
like
it wasn't that deep like but well i mean
you picked two
uh two passions that are extremely hard
to make it in they're definitely both
plan a's
yeah look if we think about every like
everyone who plays football across the
country and this amount of people make
the nfl no absolutely
i mean everyone is an artist absolutely
everybody is an artist
but it was just like that's why i said
i'm blessed bro i can't explain it it's
like
i can't explain none of this [ __ ] cause
it's like it'd just be happening and
then it happened so fast and then
since i am i am working and i keep just
doing
what i'm supposed to do like what i
think i'm supposed to do i just keep
doing it
and so the [ __ ] just happened right
under my eyes like
like looked up and like
i used to beg like i'll do anything to
get on rolling loud
now you won't ruin the lap i'm gonna
rule out i've been rolling out like two
years in a row now
that's huge so it's like you feel me but
now when i got on real loud you feel me
i did my shows now i'm not even worried
about like
that i'm all rolling loud now i'm
worried about like okay how am i gonna
have a
crazy show how are you gonna be crazy
tell me how am i to make my set i really
loud
memorable right right you know what i
mean like so everything is just like
what i'm worried about perspective man
it's just getting different yeah
yeah it's like you once you get that one
thing checked off mm-hmm
it's it's i mean i always tell everybody
to
like remember you know sometimes i got
to stop and think to myself like i
like like like try to put myself in that
mentality of like
i would have killed to be where i am now
man there was a point in time where all
i wanted to do was make 30 000
a year i was like 18. you know what i
mean like with a newborn baby like
thinking damn
if i could get 30 bands a year i'll be
rich because i'm making 12.50 an hour on
the street team like
and it's like you know you guys
sometimes you got to put yourself in
that
in that uh mentality you know just to
kind of
but it's just like when you got there no
for sure like i was like man this [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ]
yeah well like you've been going and the
other thing too is like when you when
you're when you're so
locked in bro like you don't even stop
to think about [ __ ]
you don't stop to like you pass that
[ __ ] up real fast like
it's almost like you don't stop to enjoy
it well i remember getting 500
for a show like i remember like [ __ ]
telling me like now you got to pay to
perform
yeah you can't come perform you got to
pay like
all right cool well like same [ __ ]
didn't all right come on
you uh 20 15 20. come on i need 20 bands
now
do you do you feel like uh because you
also obviously
you know going to school in san diego do
you feel like you kind of heat it up
there first
yeah definitely like because they [ __ ]
with you they [ __ ] with you
san diego yeah we did it i think we did
flux together yeah
it was pretty it was it wasn't like earl
but it's like two years ago like
but like even before then like i was
doing clubs in san diego in 2015.
oh that's crazy yeah but like i was like
a whole different artist like then like
i was like doing like trap [ __ ] like
yeah would you start to like
get into the melody [ __ ] like when i was
in atlanta
i was just listening to beats and
i came across uh papa youtube
and i heard uh the finance beat
and i was just like i'm at the same like
it's hard like um my homie was i started
playing like
and i started singing this [ __ ] and my
[ __ ] my roommate see lee
a [ __ ] came out of his room i was like
yeah that's
that's different that's it that's what
you need to be doing
and i was like yeah so the next day
after that i made atlanta
and we might have went to the club and
like his cousins and [ __ ] came maybe
some girls i'm like everybody we was
chilling in the spot
and we was playing it and it was like
this [ __ ] hard
like this tight like i was like yeah
like y'all [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
so like maybe like just throughout that
week i just started doing all kind of
beasts like that
wow and that's how i came up with [ __ ]
too for real i was gonna say like
uh people who don't know get right with
us produced by blast
and and see look i had that beast since
probably like 2014.
what do you mean you had that beast like
it was just like he just emailed it he
had sent it to me so me and blas i've
been knowing blast
right yeah so he sent me the beat but i
was only doing trap [ __ ]
okay so you were like this ain't for me
yeah he sent me some trap [ __ ] too so i
did the trap [ __ ] yeah you feel me
but it wasn't hard like i was doing trap
[ __ ] but it wasn't like
okay this nigga's different he sounded
like everybody else doing trap [ __ ] from
me to me that's how i felt
so i came back that's actually the only
song i did in la
that and i did uh naked in l.a
so when i got back to la i was doing a
session
oh okay so ray i think i'm assigned to
fc ray andre i'm signing fce
and poo you know pooh mm-hmm jeter on
laced yeah yeah so poo
uh was working with chris o'bannon so i
guess they didn't know we knew each
other
so they had us come to the studio so
we just came to the studio random and
like they was trying to get us to see if
we was gonna vibe
and i'm like bro that's chris like
that's the homie like he already knows
yeah he makes my first ever song right
my very first song ever so and that's my
boy like we've been had songs together
and stuff like that when he was in high
school
and all kind of [ __ ] so
it was just like chemistry like we did a
couple records
and when we got to he was like you got
some beats because he make beats too so
i was like
oh you don't go to know like no session
with no you're gonna make beats and ask
for it
right right right like i'ma use your
beats but so i was he was like you got
some more beats
i'm like yeah i got some hard [ __ ] like
i played the blast beat and then we was
like yeah we gonna do this one
we just knocked the song down it was
quick like 30 minutes
yeah i think it's dope that like you
like at the moment you have like
one of those ones it's like an automatic
song you have to play if you're djing
scoring is like one of those records
like right now if you go to the club
no matter what peak hour you're hearing
that record yeah
and i i like i feel like get right with
it was like
a very la record and it was huge here
but like
scoring feels like it's like it's like a
moment you know what i'm saying like
and it's a record and by the way it's a
record that y'all really like
worked because okay it's been out for a
minute bro yeah
it's been out for a hot ass minute
pandemic baby and and it's like
big bigger than you know like right now
it's probably the biggest it's been you
know what i mean
not for real i mean it's like it never
uh
i would i would say i'm blessed i'm not
gonna win it's never going backwards
um like nothing that i've been doing
since i started doing stuff is going
backwards that's dealt man you know
so i'm just you know i'm extremely
appreciative that it's it's
always a forward step no matter if it's
a slow step or you feel me no matter if
i'm standing still i'm not gonna act
like i ain't never been like
paused right i've definitely been at
like some standstills
but i've never like put a song out and
then my next song did horrible
you know and even when it like when it
has i knew why like because i didn't
drop [ __ ] like
winning against the one against the
label like i'm just trying to throw this
out and they're like bro you're
tripping like why did you do that but i
was being thirsty i wanted to have music
i thought i knew everything you thought
all right so it's like everything is a
learning experience
to me so like i never go into the world
thinking i know nothing always go in
there willing to learn
so like it don't matter like what's
going on i'll never look and make it
seem like i
got the most information because you
feel me
knowledge makes you more powerful you
know makes you the most powerful and the
most like you feeling you're wit and all
of that [ __ ]
and it's just like a [ __ ] could know so
much if you just shut the [ __ ] up and
listen to everything and everybody else
is saying that's some real [ __ ]
like oh god you just got to shut the
[ __ ] up sometimes like really
hey that's some real [ __ ] oh god if you
sometimes just like
you always hear like it's the quietest
dude in the room it's the smartest or
the most dangerous
because they're soaking everything so
much yeah so much seen so much they
already know what you got going on
and how you moving and stuff like that
and i know i'm not quite
right i talk a lot but i don't talk from
a place of
like trying to get you to understand
what i'm saying
like if i am trying to get you to
understand what i'm saying i'm trying to
get it so we both know where we're
coming from you know what i mean
like i'm not going to never try to make
nobody feel how i feel you know
but i want you to know how i feel so you
can see where i'm coming from and i want
to know how you feel so i can see where
you're coming from it's the y for me not
the what it's always the y
you know that's crazy the why not the
what yeah
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssoxofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear all right
go to oddssoxofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg kev at checkout and
you'll save 20
off of of your order underwear masks
slippers socks whatever you need they
got it oddsofficial.com keyword bootleg
have it check out save 20
um i i remember talking
you know when me and head were doing
nights together
i know there was a bunch of labels that
are trying to get at you yeah some
people dropped the ball
uh others did and you ended up with roc
nation
um what made like rock nation be like
like what what's the fit like with like
with roc nation because obviously
you know perico was over there um
and they're not they don't have the
craziest history when it comes to like
breaking new artists i mean also
specifically la artists
yeah i mean
with uh what you're saying that like
they don't have the best history you
mean
i'm not saying they have a bad history
you know what you're saying like i mean
obviously they had j
cole and they you know there's like
artists that they have everybody's from
l.a they've they really had a la artist
right another large besides right i mean
it's just like they wanted me too
shout out to the homie earl tools let me
like not shout out earl that's my it's
my guy
but it's like talking like everything i
relate everything to women because
that's
my the most experiences i've ever had in
life right now you feel me
you can't keep talking to a girl that
don't want you nothing's gonna happen
like it's cool like she want to go out
you feel me you could take her on the
date and stuff like that but that don't
mean she like you
right you know if anything you lose it
yeah you you losing if anything you cut
her off and ignore her
she's gaining that yeah you feel me so
i mean i just always look at like like
even with the recruiting process like
like with football and [ __ ] like that
like
you got to go where you're most
comfortable and just with roc nation you
feel me i felt like they wanted me just
as much as i wanted them
right you feel me not just saying that i
really wanted
them like oh i just want to be signed
into roc nation like that's the only
people i'm assigned to not saying that
right it's saying that i knew where i
wanted to be
in my life you know and i knew with this
music [ __ ]
what what's the next step and what i
needed like everybody don't need to sign
to a label
this is facts man it worked for some
people you feel me but
where i was that was the next step
like you told me i was excited it was i
was accepting that
this was this is the next step also like
opportunities like you know
having scoring like be a part of nba
games and yeah i mean like
that but nobody ever like i was already
sorry before that happened
so like i didn't know that was going to
happen but you feel me i'm gonna take a
chance on the people that's willing to
take a chance on me
that's real they genuinely gave a [ __ ]
about everything that was going on and
then i
they genuinely give a [ __ ] about
everything that i have going on
and i know that also comes with uh
per with uh your progression and uh what
you're doing like you know i also know
that if
i start [ __ ] up that or if you start
making some [ __ ] yeah you find me
them calls not gonna get answered no
more no yeah you gotta you gotta you
have to do your part as much as they got
to do their part
sometimes people don't realize that when
they sign with labels they're like
people don't fam you still got to do
your part at the end of the day
absolutely
absolutely this [ __ ] is about you at the
end of the day
and like respectively like at the end of
the day
kaelin you are a product to the
marketplace
your music is my product yeah and just
because like i'm
emotionally tired and connected to all
of this [ __ ] it doesn't matter
yeah at the end of the day consumers
have to want to consume your music
there this is a business it's not a
[ __ ]
clubhouse life change yeah it doesn't
mean that your life changed like this
[ __ ] is working that's why it's like you
got to do your part as much as they got
to do their part like a lot of people
have you seen unhappy with their labels
i'm like yeah but you're also
what are you doing what are you doing
are you unhappy with your label you
don't know if you're um if you're like
it's two sides to everything a hundred
percent you don't know if you're labeled
unhappy with you
mm-hmm you know i mean so it's just like
you gotta do what you gotta do
so you can do what you wanna do you know
that's something like me and homies live
by like
definitely go by like that's definitely
a quote we go by like you definitely
have to do what you got to do so you can
do what you want to do
because if you do what you got to do you
got room for whatever
do what you got to do already yeah i
mean
i mean it's a it's a simple thing you're
saying but it's like yo
you hear [ __ ] complain about
their job or
like i want this i want that or yo uh
why can't i go on vacation it's like yo
cuz you ain't put you gotta obviously
put you
there's like there's no excuses for
nothing bro exactly
like there's no excuse you look in the
[ __ ] mirror i look at it i look man
that's exactly how i look at it kev
man if you telling me that i gotta do a
b and c
you don't give a [ __ ] what going on in
between that i could complain
i could talk [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] but i
got to do a b and c
i got to do it because this is what i
need to do to get to where i want to be
clearly i'm [ __ ] with y'all
because y'all know where i want to be
right you feel me everybody has
the same goal eventually you feel me in
the long run no matter if their goal is
a personal goal
right their goal is for you because this
doesn't like a lot of [ __ ] be like man
they don't [ __ ] with me like that
you ain't doing this for me you're doing
this for you in the interim of somebody
doing something for themself they're
doing it for you too
because your success is based off of
them their success is best off for you
their success is based off everything
that i'm doing
yeah so you feel me like
i'm a cool dude right right like i'll be
chilling like are you feeling me i feel
like i
i'm not no like i'm gonna be trying to
anchor all extra tough and [ __ ] like
that and then i'm a people's person
yeah i don't have a problem with people
i [ __ ] with people right right but at
the same time
a lot of people get that misconstrued
with thinking i'm so friendly
i just you feel me i know it'd be going
on like you feel me and i know that
everybody doesn't have to act that type
of way with me so you feel me
i'm just appreciative of everybody doing
their best with me
you know i mean as long as you're doing
the best i think that you could do
for what you're supposed to be doing
right we can do it but you don't got to
like [ __ ] be taking [ __ ] too personal
you don't got to [ __ ] with me to do your
job good
got some real [ __ ] i don't gotta [ __ ]
with you to do my job good let's do what
we supposed to do let's get this [ __ ]
done together therefore when you look at
your resume
and i'm on your resume for the [ __ ]
that's a good look it's a good look and
i look at my resume
and you on my resume for the [ __ ] you
did for me i can't talk bad about you do
your job
you do what you're supposed to do we're
not here for that you feel me that's
some real [ __ ] man
oh god that's some real [ __ ] um
with the uh extended version of the
project coming out the deluxe version
what's your favorite out of those new
six they all my babies man
all of them yeah i'm emotional that's
fair i mean it's gotta be harder i mean
like
it would be like at the end of the day
there's a reason why they made the album
because i'm sure you had like
30 other songs you could have choose
yeah no actually it's been like 30
deluxes
that's what i'm saying yeah so those had
to be the six that you love no i mean
like
a [ __ ] with dirt heavy you feel me i
[ __ ] with they
like like his homies and [ __ ] is my
homies like said like c3 and sparrow and
all the [ __ ] like duty load
like you feel me i mean it's good it's i
mean look dirk right now is on fire bro
yeah but not even on no dick riding [ __ ]
cause a lot of [ __ ] be trying to get
close to [ __ ] because of what [ __ ]
got going on
it ain't even about that like i
literally like
like you feel me i literally [ __ ] with
them and just like
be at the studio i'll be with them these
like right we
ordered me some food too fool right it's
good like that like
like i [ __ ] with them [ __ ] so like
it's cool like big zoo all of them
[ __ ] like
i'd be cool with them and i'm not saying
that i'm best friends with them [ __ ]
but right
like you was on that show in a z that
like fake got shot up but it didn't
actually get shot up someone just
dropped the mic
yo that [ __ ] was late that [ __ ] looked
like a [ __ ]
she was crazy that [ __ ] looked like a
hot ass mess people was getting trampled
all kind of [ __ ] that was like
robbed and all kind of [ __ ] yo that was
like the first big show in phoenix since
cove it happened that she was huge it
was like 10 000 people i know and there
was only supposed to be like seven
thousand
it was like ten thousand they busted the
gate down yeah they knocked the gate
down so hello people were there they
didn't pay that [ __ ] was
it oh my god just come [ __ ] it
yeah just pull up you don't need a
ticket this [ __ ] just comes this [ __ ]
crazy out here were you there when like
the mic got dropped and everyone started
freaking the [ __ ] out standing on the
speaker
oh man and then i put that [ __ ]
i was looking at people up under me
running into the uh you know
like the crossbows that be crossing
people running
getting knocked down like oh my [ __ ]
security guards
snatched me down [ __ ] made like a a
[ __ ] tp on top of me they really
thought somebody was shocked i'm like
bro get off me
oh my god y'all man me the night before
that in san diego they start fighting in
the club
you feel me they snatched me off the
stage in the club i'm like bro y'all
keep doing me like that i'm six foot
like you're not a [ __ ]
you're not a [ __ ] athlete man right
i'm gonna get down bro stop don't be
snatching but i love them you feel me
they doing what they supposed to do
but it's just like that's yeah that show
looked crazy happening you know how that
[ __ ] goes man
nah for sure um did you ever like
you know obviously coming from sdsu uh
marshall falk
yeah kawhi leonard yeah you ever link
with any of those guys
i mean like marshall [ __ ] used to come
to talk to us and [ __ ] like that all the
time so like you feel me i know who bro
is and um uh like kawhi
kawhi like quiet yeah he's interesting
guys
he's like you got to be his friend to be
around yeah
but i didn't see him like [ __ ] putting
me back up like park on the
in front of the gym like ain't no
parking lot like he's gonna put a
maybach up in front of the gym
so like you feel me i ain't seen kawaii
and [ __ ] like that and just seeing bro
like
i was still playing football because he
ordered me like he graduated when i got
there
gotcha so you feel me like oh you seen
him come back he's originally from the
ie right yeah
yeah but like you feel me like aq and
[ __ ]
like i [ __ ] with aqaq play basketball up
there and he would make music and [ __ ]
now until you rap
that's my boy though you feel me but he
knew all of them so just hit me [ __ ]
with him i got to see them sometimes
like him and
like dwayne polly like that's want to be
no like good homies and [ __ ] like that
and then
i feel like when we talk to blue bucks
did they say that they play did they did
because
they used to play football yeah they
said you used to play football with you
right football against each other and
[ __ ] like that
yeah like oh god i was trying to play
with them but i ended up playing for
morning park i played i was going to
play for the demos with them [ __ ] play
for the demos
i ended up playing from the park i mean
my cousin ended up going over there
because we moved to compton
but like bro the world's so small me and
one take [ __ ] play
football together crazy every little
this [ __ ] is small
like like small
why do you think now in la there's
such a high level of camaraderie as to
where like
the previous era of la music i feel like
the previous couple eras of la music it
seemed like there was a lot more
division
obviously we said we weren't gonna make
it like that everyone works together
and we said we weren't gonna make it
like that like you feel me everybody has
their own personal politics
you can't get into that right that comes
automatically with with
just being from l.a but the respect
right now is high yeah for each other
because
you feel me people are starting to
realize like you feel me
nobody is going to respect us as a whole
unless we respect ourselves yeah and
yeah moving together that's what
atlanta's was doing so well for so long
you got to risk they got to respect us
as a whole we got to have each other
back and like you feel me we can't never
put aside gang banging because that [ __ ]
real
you feel me gang banging is really real
the [ __ ] is out here gang banging like
don't think [ __ ] not really gang bang
cause [ __ ] is doing that
but at the same time like
not to i don't want to never make this
sound weird because i don't ever want to
disrespect nobody
but uh a lot of people would say that
the [ __ ] that's making music is not
game banging and that's not true
because [ __ ] is gang banging too but
as a man first there comes a point where
you have to realize like this
opportunity out here
you know what i mean i mean everybody
moving together is stronger than
everyone being
absolutely but not just even saying just
from a personal standpoint like i don't
gangbang
right so i'm not in all i don't have the
same policies as everybody else
right you feel me so i could go right
here go right there go do this go do
that go to that i'll be cool
you feel me but a lot of [ __ ] can't do
that but when it's time to do the music
like [ __ ] having shows and [ __ ] for
some reason [ __ ]
is respecting each other so they let
everybody else yeah i mean i always tell
everybody when rj and greedo did that
show
on stage together that was the first
versus battle
that was hard as a [ __ ] and
nothing bad happened nothing bad
happened but that was just like
to show it could happen that [ __ ] was
crazy you feel me strong happened but
the city's just live bro like right now
because it's like everybody really
know each other and everybody really
like i'm really a fan of the homies
like i'm really if i really like their
music i like what they doing and i want
them to
do whatever they want to do so if it's
anything like you feel me
if you having a show where i would not
come right why wouldn't i come here so
i'm not doing [ __ ]
i'm not hating on you because when i
have a show coming to my [ __ ] yup yup
yup and you feel me [ __ ] just cool
like
it it's harder to hate on a [ __ ] it's
way harder
that's true it is way harder because you
really have to
pick point pick apart what you hate
because this [ __ ] could be doing
something that this [ __ ] that you like
is doing they doing
it's so much easier to show love it's
easy yeah it's easy to be like oh yeah
and you go to sleep at night without
just feeling don't worry about no [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying man at night man
you start
hating you starting you got it putting
that energy in there yeah
[ __ ] like man everybody running their
own race like my
my success is not based off of anybody
else's success because i don't have to
be here at
all right that's real you feel me this
[ __ ] is not like this is just cause it's
happening to me it wasn't supposed to
happen to me
like you feel me like i didn't like
ain't nothing written that this was
going to happen for me
nobody is uh owed anything bro nobody
you feel me and i can't and if you
trying to base your success off somebody
else's success you ain't gonna never be
happy
facts that that's the worst part about
never be happy
the rap game in general is people they
they
you know i call it pocket watching it's
like [ __ ] is too busy
watching what everyone else is doing and
then
having that psych themselves out and you
don't even be knowing what you're going
on yeah
it makes life bro if you pay so much
attention to what somebody's doing is
maybe doing better than you it makes you
second guess what you're doing
man [ __ ] be wearing fake jewelry
they have fake clothes yeah all kind of
[ __ ] you trying to keep up with a [ __ ]
you don't know what he got going on
some [ __ ] don't even rap some [ __ ]
are really street [ __ ] and just got
money
some [ __ ] got good jobs some [ __ ] be
in the navy and they getting a check
every month yeah they gonna get they
check every month
something is disabled getting uh what is
what's that [ __ ] called when you know
disability disability
ssr [ __ ] just getting money from
everywhere yeah yeah so why are you
worried about this [ __ ] you don't got
nothing to do
that's real you need to worry about you
get you some money
like you feel me need to be worried
about the wrong [ __ ] that's why i think
it's dope is because i think that that
was
maybe like a symptom of like also like
you know it's it it seems like
with like guys like yourself one take
jay blass bino
ruchi everyone you know they're just
doing everyone's doing them
and yeah and it's like it's it's with
positivity it's with
camaraderie and like nobody's like
ah well not man this [ __ ] ain't this
[ __ ] man
blast is man blast ain't [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i'm my [ __ ] harder than
the black [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that's my boy no but you
i'm just saying that as an example
because he because blast would be the
guy everyone could look at and be like
god this motherfucker's on fire it feels
some type of way but why would you
why was that some weirdo [ __ ] like why
would you hate on that that nigga's
some weirdo [ __ ] he's doing his thing
that doesn't mean that you're not gonna
get there
no that just means like yo be happy man
he's doing his thing
absolutely like people be getting too
caught up in what everybody else says
because it don't really be
it's not it's the it's their their team
people around me you got to do this you
got to do that man we got to do a work
for us
yup we got to do a work flight stick to
the game plan bro
put your put your head down and get to
it i look at it like this i'll give you
a million dollars right now
you feel me i'm gonna get a million
dollars right now you got a million
dollars now you're a millionaire
no what now what exactly so you're going
to keep doing everything that you've
been doing right you're going to go live
your life
also i mean with the blast conversation
the guy's been making music for
years 10 16 years no since i go eight
seven
we're talking to jason castro about it
he said that he made his first song with
blasto no wait yeah like
we've been making songs for years but
not just even not even talking about
blasphemy no but just in general what
you were saying like yeah like why okay
cool here's
a million dollars now what are you gonna
do yeah no but not even that is just
saying like
because i hear the conversation there's
that is a conversation they can't act
like it's not a conversation
but bro going up he doing his thing who
is to say that
next year i won't have a year like i
mean you're having a year
yeah but i'm just saying like you feel
me from what the conversations be like
you know what what people politics is
and how people like view it
like all right he having his time he's
going up
i'm proud of my god you feel me i'm
happy for him who is to say that i won't
have a time even if it's next year it's
next month next week
10 years from now well also i can still
get to wherever i need to be
you know every everyone wins when
someone wins like that
you know what i'm saying yeah man like
it's big for the city because now
everybody's looking at the city
exactly bro you feel me it's like
everyone's gonna win like well like i
mean think
like you know [ __ ] kendrick lamar you
know what i mean
what happened like you know kendrick
then the whole label was just
on cue we got to see q in the as it's
the superstar he's getting grammys
exactly you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] getting grammys this [ __ ]
real out here yeah so i just think i
think la music is in a good position man
and obviously you know you're in the
forefront of that and
you know the project is uh
how many first of all how many songs are
you sitting on
like like a lot guess a number
50 more george
how many songs we said no
175 to 200 songs he just said that's
like ready to go that's tupac
[ __ ] but that's ready to go we got like
a whole another hard drive full of [ __ ]
that's some tupac little wayne [ __ ] man
you do you um when you go in and like
record is your writing process like
like just coming up with a melody first
and punching into the lyrics are you
like actually right like
no i just whatever i hear just go in the
booth and just lay it down and then
literally like
yesterday it was the first time i ever
tried to like hear all the beats
before i recorded it and i was like the
worst process i've ever
done in my life like like yo we're in
the car play some beats no
no you're in the studio throw some [ __ ]
on i'ma go in the booth put the
headphones on and figure it out like
literally whatever beat they play first
whatever beat you play first in the
studio i'm gonna go do it right now
oh that's [ __ ] crazy put it on like
unless i just don't like it
yeah unless there's some trash like not
me like not even i'd be trash it's just
not because it's not for you yeah you
feel me but the first one i hear like
i look around the room i'm looking
around the room i'm gonna look at george
i'm gonna look at the homie i'm looking
at him and look at everybody they're
gonna be like
they start doing this all right load it
up fire let's go let me roll up real
quick we're trying to get right
well look uh friday it's out go go
support go stream that [ __ ] run it up 7
16. man two for uh two to the deluxe
rolling loud you're gonna be new york or
miami and la right miami la
slit go get them tickets for the tour
coming to a city near you
two for real